I liked it it was still stupid yeah I
liked it I agree with that but I really
let me tell you how stupid the movie was
the movie was so stupid that in the
movie they pointed out how stupid it was
[Music]
poor Griffin is tonight there's a crazy
yet go on [ __ ] no one you would have
known I was uh congrats on the premiere
did you watch it Griffin yeah I've
already seen it a bunch of times I don't
know we just got on we'll know tomorrow
depends on like how many people actually
like to show you know I mean mm-hmm ya
know for sure
destiny just continues to be boring try
for you know the news the new stuff
comes out tomorrow's tomorrow Tuesday
yeah I know that's kind of how I feel
like it at the Oscars and I'm like yay
one more straight and be more new helmet
it's gonna be great
it's the one day Griffin well what it's
the final showcase for the door guys on
Monday I'm gonna mean the final Adams
been watching for the past like five
weeks so is this to win the best or guy
award or yeah he picks whichever one I
hope you get it bro
no I hope that's cool I hope you win
then you can finally afford better
internet the hell Happy New Year video I
know I'm Marco Polo there we go you ever
seen that app no not at all what is it a
video sending video app just like put it
that guy what if that guy said Griffin
something super important like it
rocking Griff is like peasant listen to
it in 10 months
Griffin the world's gonna end 10 months
later yeah why would they call Griffith
the world's just maybe he can help
better than you would it needs to know
that the world is gonna end
it's Eric Griffin yeah we muscled his
last words
oh my god oh my god just what I said
I've showed you guys watching see thanks
big it's gonna be even like even less
like they got they shot their wad early
because everybody wanted to see it
because of all the ten movies but like
in two weeks bro it was awesome this
movie's gonna be like I I just can't
watch this I'm gonna it's not gonna be
it's not gonna be like pandering it I
think it did I think it already yeah
because people because you want to see
it it's got it's got a have stain now
over time people are watching the movie
twice three times and four times they're
not doing they're not gonna do that I'm
telling you I talked to people I know
I've got it three times never generally
no like six people that's your right
people I've seen it like three times but
you can already see like that it already
is less than 50% of the box office this
week next week it over 50% again and
then that'll be it and I'm telling you
he's not people don't really like also
anyway you guys think everyone I have
talked to likes it but you grow every
single one well did they see you twice
are you seeing it twice are you going
again I'll go again I want to go I don't
want to go three times but I want to I
want to see it one more time my buddy
Wes I only go through goes well Griffin
they just said it made three billion won
or something worldwide how was I don't
think anything's made that that quickly
oh I know I'm saying like they shock
they're gonna
this is that's the type of movie that
everybody wanted to see right away but
it's not gonna have staying powers what
I'm saying it's not gonna be one of
these things where people are gonna see
it 10 times like you've already seen
like once you see it once I mean that's
it
you know this in this worldwide cuts
like China and every every place in the
whole wide world look at the box office
mojo for movies worldwide I mean it's
like worldwide box office like all the
Harry Potter movies like the world does
way better than the United States yeah
but here's the thing dude total grosses
for the first Avengers was six hundred
and thirty seven knows I mean 623
million Avengers age of Ultron was four
hundred fifty nine million Avengers
affinity war is already what's been out
a week and it's four hundred and fifty
million it's it's already he just knows
off the top of his head this is a
[ __ ] nerd no I'm not sure sighs she
got up I was just looking it up I just
thought I'm just I mean I don't know you
might be right to different but I think
it's killing it right now I think it's
yeah if you've watched all these other
movies you're gonna watch this movie
everyone what is it's not like people
aren't gonna watch it what I'm this is
what I think it's like you're saying
they're not better it wasn't better than
those other movies it wasn't the best
movie in the series Civil War is way
better than that booty
I like Civil War I think so wars winter
soldier soldier soldier is the best
movie of all that in like winters winter
soldiers better first Ironman is better
first time I ran was great I like sore I
like sore Ragnarok better than this I
liked the other guys
plus its name from Rasik part I like
that first one better I'm just I'm just
saying that this movie wasn't this it
wasn't like oh my god this is the best
movie in the series I'm telling you it's
just it's alright this solo thought
everybody went to see it because if
you've seen all the goo you've already
invested the time you're not gonna not
see this movie so everybody's gonna well
put off the majority of people will
watch it one time it's gonna blow its
water Lee and then that's the end of it
see but here's the thing the question
will be if you get the sequel and you
like the sequel a lot more than you'd be
part of the series you know I mean it
wasn't meant to be a movie that was
supposed to be like happy-go-lucky like
all the other Avengers movies yeah the
stupid part here's this dooba part if
Thanos can kill half the universe with a
flick of his finger
why the [ __ ] would he keep any of them
alive
fighting against him well and he oh I
know I know but I could I could agree
with Griffin there cuz but he was trying
to be the most judicious like by just
saying like it's gonna be half of
everybody but I get what you're saying
like but that's this suspension of
disbelief like I still don't know how
Black Widow can find an alien [ __ ] with
superpowers and [ __ ] if you set up rules
in a universe if you set up the rules
you have to follow them and it's just
like here's the thing if because first
of all all they're gonna do they're
gonna do is use this time
Travel [ __ ] and then they're gonna bring
everybody back to life which is no
stupid if that's what happens this is
the stupidest [ __ ] ever why not just
kill everyone you get what I'm saying if
you've no idea rings I do like it's so
stupid you killed spider-man and black
panther if you gonna kill them and
they're what why would he leave anyone
alive
why it just as a storyteller why leave
anyone that's facing him alone
wait listen listen yeah if you're just
gonna bring them back to life in the
next movie why save them now it is so
stupid
I guess Stanley like why he wrote the
comics that's what happens in town in
the comic books yeah they just killed
all the different characters exactly the
same but Griffin so let's say even paint
that's not what I'm saying it doesn't
make any sense in this movie for
instance the stupid asian girl with the
with the dumb like you know like like
that stupid girl
this will ours the guy like attacks
people for no [ __ ] reason it can't
speak English properly like why bring
them like he should have just he would
have just killed them I'm just saying it
would that that was so stupid like this
is really dumb and when it's all said
and done you're gonna look back on it
especially when they bring everybody
back to life do you think they're gonna
use the time stone that's what makes it
even stupider
[Music]
you act you act in movies but you lost
me when you said John wick is the same
as Jack Reacher
I cannot take anything did you say John
did you see the free sweet your heads
Jack wheat your have a photographic
memory there's an outstanding detective
okay Griffin you always say you don't
get what I'm saying I want to point out
what the [ __ ] that has to do with John
wick a photographic family and there's a
detective what the [ __ ] does that have
to do dude it doesn't have anything to
do yes so that makes it the same guy
does that mean every action movies the
same if they beat up the same amount of
people basically argue that Jack Reacher
in his movie he beats up and kills a
bunch of people and John wick beats up
and kills a bunch of people if you're
trying to say if they were going in a
one-on-one battle who would win it's a
wash well what I never seen argue that
is not the same as being an idiot that
likes Avengers I didn't know and I'm not
exact but now you're going too far
you're making it you're making it too
complicated you're making it too
complicated I'm just saying
must whenever you have an opinion if I
have ever everybody I know liked
Avengers and you're the one guy that
picks it apart and you don't like it
yeah I like let me tell you how stupid
the movie was the movie was so stupid
that in the movie they pointed out how
stupid it was when the black girl goes
why the hell is the most powerful person
in Alvis upstairs when we're fighting
this are model like that
was basically the movie saying hey look
how dumb we are it was some really bad
story do you don't have to tell you
something that upset even more you know
how Thor just shows up to where
what's-his-name is like he shows up - no
no castanos was on Titan like why didn't
he do you mean when he shows up with the
axe yeah can you just show up on Titan
instead of showing up we're [ __ ] the
battle is going under man don't even get
me started and how about this
oh I'm sure having the [ __ ] play the
big giant guy that was the stupidest
[ __ ] like I was in a theater where
people were laughing and they weren't
laughing like in a good way
cuz it just looked so stupid the
Dinklage part was definitely be happy I
can't wrap my brain around this stupid
that's stupid like technology that they
have like it's just like this whole suit
is coming out of this necklace it's like
at that point it's like come on man you
set up a whole movie free movie you know
and Iron Man he's in the desert and he's
learning how to do this technology the
whole movie the whole movie so you kind
of like you suspend your disbelief that
Tony Stark is this brilliant scientist
he can come up with this stuff and then
like out of nowhere but they have this
technology that Dwarfs every technology
in the whole world and it looks like a
cartoony nonsense I just like I think it
just take well I mean you know what
that's potential growth right that's
just heightening less thing they have to
tighten it from all the last ones so how
do we make it more heightened than the
last one where you know it's in a
[ __ ] suitcase or it's in like the
helmet turns into the suit and so they
go for that I'll tell you something else
they are they already knew they made a
mistake with the third Iron Man as first
of all no one should ever die in this
universe because of that technology that
Tony Stark healed himself with you
notice how they just kind of glossed
over that like you never even hear about
that
like where where is that well didn't
beyond myself no justice they just heal
this heart though right he didn't heal
his whole no no that technology he was
like oh I'll figure it out and he
figured it out and like he killed
himself
so nope all the Avengers should be
healing themselves with that technology
but it was so they just kind of they
just let it go like the Avengers oh but
I mean okay but to be there to go but to
be fair when you're gonna do a movie
with 20 superhero yeah well it's just
never gonna be right because you got too
many ridiculous moments they never
talked about that again are you saying
are you saying like if you remember Iron
Man 3 he had the ability that from that
lady to heal so what happened technology
so you're telling me you're telling me
if this movie had a bunch of the vendors
that fall fan on sale got beat up but
they end up coming back and winning
because they all use this healing
technology you think that would be a
better movie because it's more accurate
no like what kind of dumb [ __ ] is that
who said that they're kind of implying
it because you're picking apart no
because you are you're picking up you're
picking you're picking up all these
obscure [ __ ] parts of these movies
that have nothing to do with
a movie that's two and a half hours long
and you're bitching about where's this
where's that where's this when you know
damn well they just don't have enough
one space to put in the movie and it's a
[ __ ] it's a it's a comic-book movie
and you're like dissecting every little
thing I don't know how you would have
like Thor Ragnarok and not like this
movie that doesn't make any sense to me
because Thor Ragnarok is pretty much a
bunch of [ __ ] - I like the movie but
it was stupid my difference bro I've
never really thought a movie was dumb
and liked it like is it done yeah is it
dumb humor or give me the exact name
Craig might be the worst person to ask
you know I liked it yeah
[ __ ] almost every [ __ ] Rocky movie
after 300 yeah Rocky five maybe every
every Jackie Chan every Jackie Chan boo
yeah every Jet Li yeah oh are you
talking about like you guys say the same
thing you're coming up with arguments
that not one person I've heard say
you're saying [ __ ] that nobody is saying
nobody that's not fair I think there's
there's a lot of people that haven't
beef with the vengers that's not true
the air is the end better get on the
blog's I know English
nobody likes ya none of you guys like
Peter Dinklage none of you guys like
that even loved him but not for the
reader
big enough part in the movie to worry
about yeah I was like I think the
problem is is like you're right Griffin
if you create rules you want to stick to
them but then again when you have
something this unwieldy that's been
around for so long it's just hard to
keep you know turning this [ __ ] out
I mean that's the problem with Star Wars
right now - you can't you pump this [ __ ]
out every six months and it's you know
there's just a lack of you know things
that make it as good as it could be well
this is a solo as solo has already broke
records for presale tickets I'm not
interested in seeing it I just saw I
can't
well I mean maybe I'm not making money
but are they all great films
hell no I mean you know yeah but I mean
that's the thing like at the end of the
day it's like I mean it's tough to keep
like I don't even know how these [ __ ]
start out is for many years they are and
you know what another dumb thing about
Avengers now that we're nitpicking we
all turns into a [ __ ] like that was
like for the next thing yeah nobody
knows what that was about
but it's just weird that they just go
sing a honies address vault is what's
gonna happen
yeah that's they're gonna make out
they're gonna bring out the actual like
intelligent Hulk who can do you know
they should bring out as gynaecologist
Hulk because that dude yeah crazy will
just wreak some vagina
bring your back tear up but you know
what I mean it's fair it's fair to love
and hate these things I mean my problem
is like it's tough to keep turning these
movies out and god I would hate working
on some of those that's just the
politics I think you probably made one
too many movies I think I think they
should have left out the last Thor it
just made the Avengers you know what I
mean and and the last guardians of the
galaxy I could have done without that
one and it's yeah I can this
instead of making thor ragnarok just
make the Avengers I think they made one
too many movies I actually like the
Ragnarok I thought it was funny I know
but I mentioned I know to me Ragnarok at
all you just had the Avengers I think
that then they make one two minutes I
think I think well here's my question to
anybody see the Captain Marvel trailer I
don't understand it I don't get in the
comic books Captain Marvel is the most
powerful character in the whole Marvel
Universe right yep no I get that I get
that but Captain Marvel also died when
the ones I used to read so like I don't
know the new capital they're going back
to the 90s this movie's gonna be in the
90s right but I watch the trailer and I
just it didn't nothing about it excited
me like I like she's a pilot and she
gets injected and well first of all I
think that wasn't confusing everybody
I'm yeah because you saw these people
die but then you can ride the trades and
see that they're making spider-man 2 you
can look in the trades and see that
they're all that nature I know they're
black Avenger - so you're sitting down
you're going well everybody's coming
back to life it was without a doubt the
stupidest [ __ ] that's my whole point
ok ok but I'm just going back to mom
Captain Marvel I'm saying what's the
deal with Captain Marvel because I watch
the trailer and I don't I don't
understand well you watch the fake
trailer man no they just released a new
one didn't thing where their pilot will
just make one word she's getting
injected that's not true that's that's
not the right one because I was confused
yeah a bunch of yeah what
cuz I'm done I just watched a fake
trailer well you sent me the link Frank
I don't know it was online I didn't send
you the link
I hate oh no just I'm just saying like I
just I just I was a little bit of Psych
I heard they leaked it so watch one
you're right it might have been
oh man come on dude I'm with him right
now Don Baylor's what all face oh they
did it did leaks always get you till
they make you see my god you mean like
they're they're faking they leak in it
yeah I know what you mean yeah yeah I'm
just saying I saw one that was supposed
to be a like a Harry Potter eight and it
was just like you know I was like I so
mad at myself for watching it because I
named it like something something that
would be stupid with the title to like
Harry Potter eight Poland hot dogs it
turns out that what happened they made a
play she wrote a she wrote a play so
they're doing this Harry Potter like
that let you know the kid but it's a
play it's not a movie but then they made
a trailer so you kind of like confused
cuz it's like real news and it turns out
it's not even you know it's [ __ ]
well because of this Avengers and Disney
what Disney is doing they're like you
know what if you have a universe they're
gonna make a bunch of movies in the
universes now so that's just what's
gonna be going off forever now well yeah
I mean that's but that's kind of what
the studio's have been doing just not as
quickly you know what I mean just not as
not as like nah man why did I like these
Star I like these Star Wars movies I
like looking at getting into the
universe and all that I like that I like
the idea of it I just think that they're
just rushing them out too quick cuz it's
like you know it reminds me of like
Assassin's Creed Assassin's Creed they
were releasing them every year and then
eventually the quality just went to [ __ ]
because it's like you know you're just
gonna release them every three seconds
you know what I mean it's just that
quality goes down because people are
under the gun to get you now is the same
thing with Call of Duty
I mean Call of Duty's you know kind of
burned out
they're doing that bad a little late now
I know well but that's the thing like I
mean I used to try to keep them fresh
they come with some good ideas to try to
keep them fresh but it's tough to keep
reinventing the wheel and if you're
doing it ever like once a year that's
you know I'm telling you you may I bet
you destiny does it that's neat better
do [ __ ] something cuz you know I'm
not not what a bad thing come out with a
battle royale for destiny that'll save
that [ __ ] like oh yeah they gotta do
something did cuz it's guns so you know
it is the thing is it's still a great
game to play I mean just playing any
other game the mechanical grain I mean
that's not our game is as smooth as this
game there's no no mechanics or so yeah
it's like it's just the most responsive
smoke ever oh my god there is eros eros
I can't play this right now coke I
cannot concentrate like Sarah arrow
yeah
he's talking Erewhon he sent me like
they had yeah he's here
oh man yeah come on I mean one tight
home right now nothing's going on why
don't you join the boys and play some of
this Cruz are you what okay god you
[ __ ] yeah I can't I'm tight [ __ ]
told you I [ __ ] by myself so no you
got teammates no I I'm so ready dude I'm
gonna go get like four bags I'm gonna be
banged out of my [ __ ] mind I'm ready
for Wednesday no you know all about hey
you know what you know what I you know
what I've been playing with an iron
banner is that as a risk runner because
all these people are used in that
[ __ ] Ark hmm can you just
all these pulse naso you just get a
little bit of that on you and then use
tall man I'm I've been you just melt
people do you kill what they're standing
together it's great
what's the risk run Ergon it's a good
counter to all those live although all
that Ark it's a good counter for that
yes sound like you're far away to me
movie arrow sounds like he's like
how come Loki died
that'll make any sense is he dead like
whit on ice or can [ __ ] let you know
get shot by a son but Loki can't survive
Wow Loki is kind of low he's also the
god of mischief like you know he'd be
that [ __ ] before where he was dead yeah
where we don't know why would he leave
Thor alive it's I didn't get that Loki
you got killed I didn't make any sense
had a third getaway I don't even
remember how he got away he got away
didn't he could survive in space no yeah
but didn't didn't they blow up something
didn't he just yeah Pratt was looking
fat though what was that about huh gee
maybe maybe they're bringing orange and
red bastards I know he's gonna play the
best role ever as Andy right I be like
probably one of the only people like for
that I'll be so right for that you know
what I'm kind of pissed off that we
already saw Ruth die once
well I'm not still Rocking oh man the
Orpheus rigs don't work with the 3-shot
huh glad you guys glad you guys really
like I was talking I'll be back in a
minute
wait why wouldn't they work with the
three chef's new work oh wait
I don't know if they work with that
thing you still have to get all those
kills
and
hey Griffin will happen with those three
Showtime clothes clapping with with
those free Showtime codes
clearly here you do I said what happened
with the Showtime codes I know they
usually tend to like when the show comes
out to have some kind of code like yeah
you can spend that [ __ ] but let's bring
that [ __ ] DLC no dude I think are you
guys playing destiny what are you guys
doing yeah I'm just in orbit all right
I'm in pub G Craig [ __ ] just left my
ass [ __ ] high right oh [ __ ] someone
say hi we are a banner yeah no I want
any [ __ ] honesty Silver Surfer man
what are they gonna do good Silver
Surfer I don't know but I think talking
up Fantastic Four yeah they do
yeah that's why yesterday right all
right wait but they're supposed to be
buying out Fox or tried to butcher the
world ooh we could do you like Marvel
doesn't get it right every time because
the people that make x-men they suck
dick except for like when you saw those
claws go through that guy's head for the
first time
that [ __ ] was like whoa
I was like oh we've been missing here's
well here's another sorry
that was so let's let's say they
finished the Avengers right and they
finished this like whatever this this
path they're on like eventually people
are gonna be like alright we're done
with all of these characters so like
what's next like even if they reboot it
and start a new group like they did
spider-man like what are they what
stories are they gonna tell like with
all those same characters you know they
can do they've gone too far to do that
man I know but that's what they're
talking about they're gonna have to like
I mean there's definitely characters
they haven't touched in the Marvel
Universe but I'm just saying like I'm
curious to see like what they can do
after this is all done I'm too burned
out to watch another whole beginning of
Ironman you know what I mean like I
can't do a new Ironman and like start
that series all over again I'll tell you
what looks awful I hate to say it as
venom venom looks just I don't know I'll
tell you it's rated it looks like the
graphics are rated negative 10 the
animation look don't forget about that
the Netflix universe 2 is still alive
you know like Luke Cage and wise no but
I'm saying like that's true but like
that's a whole separate thing like I
mean the Avengers are always separate to
like I mean in the comics they never
really had like guardians of galaxies in
the offenders universe there doesn't
gonna be the guy that take down fans how
awesome just this blind guy comes in was
Daniel
[ __ ] they're gonna go Coco take John
wick over dared oh I never said that
John I never said John Drake would beat
Jack Reacher even though I like John
like way more because it's a better
movie I'm gonna flat out say it first
Jack Jack the first Jack Reacher was
good that second one was a piece of [ __ ]
oh my god
I think we overthink that Jack Reacher
John wick and the equalizers jason
stathom when I guess his accent won't
work but his look will be great for
Silver Surfer what just CGI over silver
I'm a random crossover like van knows
verse Optimus Prime
yeah that'd be cool but they'll probably
get there don't you worry it's in the
comics like transformers versus he-man
and what did you eat did you hear that
uh what's-his-face sold the Power
Rangers right subong yeah he sold him to
Hasbro oh look out for Michael Bay
thinking the next Power Rangers yeah
well he produced and he produced the
last one I don't think so
maybe I'm wrong about that I don't know
I think we'll be cool as if Thanos gets
killed by Howard the Duck that'll
totally surprise everyone just complete
silence I said he was in the end just
like a deafening a deafening silence
my Guardians a gutsy one do you remember
him at the end of that that was Howard
the Duck oh my god guys don't even
remember that [ __ ] I don't know man I'm
getting burned out on all these like
sequels like I'm just not excited about
any Star Wars anymore or Disney Studios
those killing it man they got well yeah
fourteen fourteen of those like
highest-grossing movie [ __ ] man killing
it that's for sure
anyone play some pub G no I'm probably
gonna get off of them and I'm [ __ ]
hello I'm beat tonight
what's Finity war than petrol - oh yeah
ant-man and wasp that's next
oh that's right they're doing another
ant-man movie I know Mike oh they're
doing Dark Phoenix movie Captain Marvel
movie you know right there just cause
any of a [ __ ] gambit movie that's
gonna be weird
oh damn bro we all forget cool cool yeah
oh yeah and then new New Mutants is
coming now that's gonna be a long time
no no New Mutants is coming out August
2nd this year
I'm looking forward to that no mute it's
cause it's crazy I don't know maybe
you're right
yeah wait you're right yeah yeah you're
right it's why they why they postponed
it so long
cuz it's good to do reshoots man
they added somebody to uh they added a
character and they had to do reshoots I
didn't know that then they're gonna do a
black widow movie and an X 23 movie god
damn I'll go to that out of [ __ ] to
Scarlett Johansson's ass [ __ ] wax 23 I
think they should have done the Black
Widow movies before they did this movie
that's what I think like yeah enough of
her already
it's kind of hard to pump her up yeah
well that's what I'm saying like like
they should have just a fighter fighting
the alien [ __ ] and the last one like
that movie like explain how buff and
crazy she is I don't know that's in
brass backer soon yeah
yeah I mean I don't know I mean it you
know people love that [ __ ] they'll keep
seeing it
we gotta get Griffith in the Marvel
Universe dude you should be Galactus be
a great Galactus dirty did that don't
know but that was whacked that Galactus
was whacked that dude was like a [ __ ]
storm cloud no I mean it's the real
movie looks good but I don't understand
how to get our mast I think it looks bad
man I think it looks terrible
I like great that guy's a great actor
though man I love our that's where it
was so bad
yeah the animation looks like spawn for
the nineteen student yeah I don't like
agreeing with Craig office never agreed
with me but I'll take I don't think
there was enough to see of it to really
know I saw his face with the stupid
coming around as yeah god dude it looks
the animation looks so bad like that's
embarrassing like in this day actually
on these trailers and stuff it looks
back because I thought that nanos look
horrible in the trailers man I was like
oh my god this cartoon character is
gonna be the syllabus
Urmi yeah but better just does a movie
thing it looks a little bit better in
the movie venom looks like he's like
rubbed down with Crisco dude like he
should look like I don't know it's just
upsetting them into that store he's like
all the moist looking and yeah it's an
alien symbiote see like what yeah but
dude if you watch the McFarlane comics
do you look tight
[ __ ] not all [ __ ] creepy so you're
saying make a movie party no I said in
the comics not the cartoon and then
first dolls and secondly it'd be dope
with that carnage in it that would be
they need to make a car next movie rated
R that would be so [ __ ] awesome do
you know guys live in I mean I don't
know either I don't have any good
feelings about venom I do I think it's
gonna be I think he'll be just as
business Super Mario Brothers movie I
remember the supermarket everyone wants
it this is so bad they're supposed to be
making new Nintendo movies and then I
was a supermarket origin movie know that
me dope the Super Mario on over Taiwan
at a super Mario's origin movie is that
what it was yeah but they're supposed to
be making I would love to see like a
dope Zelda movie like Zelda's the one or
Metroid those those could be good
Metroid would be awesome yeah that's
right it would be amazing
yeah but how you gonna make that
knowledge
Sonic the Hedgehog supposed to do an
uncharted movie that got canceled
almost every like what's been though
there's barely there's really been no
good video game movies are one that have
been great Sasson scream blew it
that's I didn't see it if L agree was so
stupid oh my god it was so bad but you
know what's sad is like the games are
actually like really well-written like
the second one and everything we're
really well done and so then to like see
that crappy movie was just depressing
like even the way they made the stupid
system work it was just like well yeah I
didn't watch it how bad was it
it's bad it doesn't even track like it's
confusing and weird and uh it just just
it felt like I got like 3/4 of our movie
and they're just like that's good enough
just put it out
are there enough people playing it seems
like this other team I don't know
there's there people that write okay
yeah one guy catch it though I was like
it doesn't seem like if anybody playing
it right doesn't seem as fast pace
[Music]
Griffin what's your take on Kanye
I think he's trolling everybody yeah I
think someone said he's doing like a
Coffman thing yeah everybody and he's
gonna make a you might make it he might
make a fool of Donald Trump you come out
with some alban one of his songs will be
like [ __ ] Donald Trump but I mean still
about that whole slavery thing like even
if you're trolling that seems ridiculous
yeah but you know you should actually
like if you watch like a lot of this
stuff is being translated into something
else like I think it's a dumb comment
but if you actually listen to him he's
nice like it's taken out of context the
way they're showing a hundred really is
he really is talking about he's talking
about the slave the slave mentality he's
not talking about like like no choice to
get on boats and get raped and beaten up
no no he's talking about the later you
know that's what he was trying to talk
about he just can't articulate yeah but
he did say 400 years seems like a choice
like relating to that time pay he's
saying like yeah but he's not talking
about like if it's this long like how
can he say how can you still be a slave
this long if it's not mental like that's
when he was trying to allude to and just
did here but that's work that I did
didn't articulated properly if you
listen to my that's what happened you're
not hearing in what he was saying but
when you put it out there by his
original comment about Trump if you read
it he wasn't supporting Trump you know
but then the way everybody got on him
he turned it I think he just was like
okay [ __ ] it you know oh yeah the Trump
thing I could believe is a troll thing
but the slavery thing and I know what
you're saying and I saw the full thing I
just think it's a he might not have
articulated it correctly but the way it
came out was bad like I would you know
I'm just saying like I mean you should
be careful with what you say and how you
say it I mean you know a [ __ ] that
shadows a rapper how many know I thought
the best thing ever was when like Snoop
Dogg put a picture of him upward he'd
just like white Kanye I was pretty funny
one yet yeah on it he's gonna come out
with some dynamic album everybody's
gonna be on it yeah I'll tell you I'll
tell you there's not gonna be honest
dick and that's me cuz I don't even like
dick I don't like to 808 album thank you
very much lettuce you got to I get it
you got a watch donald glover new video
childish games oh it's so well done this
a artistic masterpiece Trayvon's fathers
in the beginning it's just an artistic
masterpiece man you see the pale white
horse and I watched it I'm gonna check
it out I watched him on this oh no I
didn't think that episode was that funny
though sadly how the guts not definitely
care oh the John what's-his-name what's
the guy from Barry
he was good his episode was good the
Mego sketch was on too bad I thought
that was pretty funny and the
a kanye place was pretty funny kanye
place was pretty funny but i don't know
I kind of was let down with the Lando
one like it started out kind of funny
and I was like over it after love I'm in
it I mean the Barbies are also kind of
like it was a good idea but it kind of
just didn't go anywhere that's what I
don't know that diversity get hired
instead of [ __ ] talent well [ __ ] you
know what street maybe be a team player
Frank Jesus Christ I'm talking mad [ __ ]
right now Dawg get pissed president look
good eros hey y'all watch it coach it
I'm not playing so yeah I don't know I
just I'm not really excited about
anything lately as far as movies or
anything black near fifth season that's
about it for me ones that go probably
flying around after summer I would guess
Fahrenheit we're building one Fahrenheit
451 might be good that looks handout
Oh shove it there you go you put you on
blast
no no but both through my stream yeah it
doesn't matter yeah it goes right
through mine so we got you all don't
worry don't worry don't worry the next
podcast is just gonna be you speaking
for that five minutes yeah I'm just
gonna cut that out let's cut that we're
not gonna get that's it we'll just may
get the trailer don't worry I'll be the
job in fact I'm gonna stop twitching
because nobody's watching my [ __ ]
anymore I'm not twitching anymore I hate
this dude I don't know why it just
doesn't Twitter so buggy I'm
Amos there we go
oh man I don't know it's just a lot even
game wise I mean other than the update
for destiny what's coming out soon
that's exciting
I mean Dada war was great was you guys
have Playstations that fullness came
inside eyes will boner can leech on it
up there's five is that next hot title
that I'm looking forward to how are we
getting our ass beat right
I don't know man I'm not doing terrible
game next how much time for you Goodman
I'm gonna wait and watch the whole
season but I don't want to watch it like
one episode at a time just just don't do
it that way I jump right into this
tether
feather it up
10 kill streak I I'm pretty dead tired
I'm gonna go crash I'll talk to you boys
soon all right correct good night guys
later bro
mmm our spreader just got the business
throw a knife
so they lost
oh I hear a hammer yep you not know
where I think it's in the middle it's
going towards bi saying Eppie yeah
ah
Zone B lost opponent made a power play
in captured zone baby
all that I should be thin
it's almost dead over here
five minutes in the face they should not
be able to just walk up to you
punchy it's got a bubble
my staff and handlers
all I can do I can't get this last
challenge we have to kill five people in
one life I just cannot do that one it's
not a daily challenge I think that's a
video challenge yes yes the daily
challenge for for our iron banner hey
what the [ __ ] is that you're playing
Tara connected well it's [ __ ] it's
real addicting it's not well what is it
it's like a blend of [ __ ] Dynasty
Warriors and World of Warcraft oh oh
it's not it's super dangerous is it free
yeah
I probably got one more Griffin and you
watch that a wild wild country
documentary sirs oh yeah man it's
horrible we should yeah I'm on that
right I'm like I'm still I'm still
looking up still a half way you know
yeah yeah that's why we're on that it
was great yeah I didn't even know if
that was a [ __ ] thing I mean either
man I don't think anybody yeah
that's just bananas man yeah what's that
but Sheila is a badass yeah man she's a
csavage dude she don't [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
and still as she still doesn't know like
Oh being old she's [ __ ] she don't
give a [ __ ]
oh you're a [ __ ] man [ __ ] about you or
your mama
I watched Cobra Kai - I'm [ __ ]
unfuckin ah oh how is that dude he's in
that it's awesome bro it's [ __ ]
awesome
really well done I like the way they do
it cuz not that nobody's the bad guy
like you can just you can look at it
from different people's perspectives and
it's just this it's mutual oh really
yeah it's [ __ ] it's dope though
which would do with your gunslinger
which treaty you use the top or the
bottom I use whatever's the outlaw I
think it's the top yeah it's the top the
six shot
yeah I really neglected my hunter man
I've got any good armor nothing what's
your main would you say what do you play
at the Maghreb is it warm up there yet
well the one I play with the most yeah
yeah yeah usually played the warlock the
both yeah but then once I start playing
with another character I kid I get
addicted to it so then I just like I've
been playing with the hunter now for
like the last couple weeks
yeah and I've been out but then I'll go
to my tightness and it'll just be like
tighten all day you know I mean I just I
don't know this game is weird like yeah
I was using and I never played Titans
obviously but I was playing with Craig's
Titan and I actually went to Sentinel
The Sentinel was my favorite not all
that's pretty good
it's having that choice between I liked
uh the hammer Kyle of that that grenade
the thermite grenade their names and
after my grenade great good somebody's
in front of you you know that's great it
does a lot of damage
that [ __ ] comes out tomorrow the update
work Tuesday technically but Tuesday
yeah so technically
yeah I'm pumped for that escalation
protocol or whatever that new horde mode
that's gonna be dope you like prison of
elders that's what is kind of kindly
gonna be like oh yeah I miss I miss
prison of elders that was fun yeah
and then ranked pvp I'm [ __ ] excited
for that
opponent claims Ownby
pay some love Gears of War man that was
the best yeah here's a little old though
on that chord oh yeah work yeah
we captured the song advantage is yours
and that's how you get ground this is
the moment iron Lords live for
strike as one
zone eight lost
I will never forget your deeds
weapon deposits Thanks how that guy
survived
hey guys along with a throwing knife in
that's like nothing happened and that ya
throwing magic pretty weak you they
gotta be like a finishing finishing
thing mostly what I use in this like if
you get a Titan trying to charge any
like Craig like just running straight
out of you at the shoulder charge right
leg right leg that's when yeah cuz then
you can get the headshots I remember
when we played a private investing one I
got Craig that thing in one game I think
I killed almost seven throwing guys
ah damn it
stuff
you look pleased
you guys done now we're selling this
game trench like if I want to play one
more go to bed
I'm gonna go to bed
oh hi guys hey girl bombs going off
that's the type of game
oh he's selling her oh my god that guy
survived my Golden Gun oh my god
The Sentinel survived my Golden Gun
Sentinels tape they can take lint three
men and [ __ ] crazy oh is that right
yeah oh man then the only way you can
have stupid the only way you can one
shadow shock it take away people yeah
well the only way you can one shot you
can if you use the bottom tray that's
the only thing you can get persistent
damage so like if you get a precision
shot on them you'll kill them
so my mother just blinking all over the
place
nope you tried this no the BA we need to
take this off take seat
you captured some seed sown advantages
zone be lost in the dark image Rico
thank God
a plug they got believe they got a
shotgun on B now - five minutes
the pendulum could swing either way
orbs horeb city not be sitting down with
a shotgun on me
[ __ ] oh man I'm gonna kill him but
they're gonna guy coming from the other
side
you're a weapon defied
the slam that our staff
Wow good counter
this isn't over
it's not nothing
when [ __ ] they don't have their supers
Jesus everyone not believe ever survived
by Golding that everyone like one of
them on Titan god they're all Slammers
or something that makes me not want to
use the golden
you know that's probably
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]